good
[Music]
hi, how are you? in 3 gonzález with
the most outstanding headlines for
today wednesday october 14th the
president will hold another campaign in
nevada next sunday according to
review shift sources the president of tram
will visit the state in an on-air event
free in the co and another in las vegas' his
campaign team did not confirm details
about his trip the last event
held in henderson received fines
for not complying with the rules
established to prevent the spread of the
coronavirus
in october is awareness month
for the  domestic violence last night 5
non-profit organizations
gathered at the welcome to
las vegas' sign that was lit
purple in commemoration of all the
victims during the pandemic
local groups have noted a 42% increase
in calls related to violence
domestic
el encore schedule change wynn resort
it was announced in a statement that this
property will work only from the
j  Thursday afternoons until Monday at
noon the company said they had made
these changes due to the low demand
generated by the pandemic the
operation of the wynn hotel will continue
for the whole week now we turn to
the weather forecast today will be the
hottest day of the week  with a
temperature reaching 94 degrees
but as of tomorrow the winds will return
and these will cause temperatures
in the high 80s.